okay we have to demand that corporate
media live fact-check Donald Trump's
coronavirus press briefings you all may
know that I've been covering the press
briefings live roughly five six days a
week usually I miss one each week that
Trump does I make an effort to be as
caught up as possible on all of the
things Donald Trump is likely to lie
about so that in real time I can fact
check it when Donald Trump says
chloroquine looks really good I'm ready
to tell you that it is one of dozens of
things being looked at but the early
trials aren't so good and a lot of them
lack the rigor that a true randomized
controlled peer reviewed trial would
have okay Trump says chloroquine plus
azithromycin why not what do you have to
lose and I make an effort to be ready
with what you might have to lose and the
side effects chloroquine poisoning so on
and so forth this week Trump shifted to
zinc zinc does not cure coronavirus and
we have to be ready to talk about that
Trump said last week sometimes a scarf
is better than a mask at preventing
contagion that's not true we have to be
ready with the data there's been a huge
debate about whether corporate media
outlets should air the Trump press
briefings or not should they skip the
Trump part and go right to the doctors
well the problem and that is very often
in the midst of the lies Trump is
actually announcing important policy
during his part whether it's an
extension of the social distancing
guidelines or whatever Trump says no one
could have predicted this we've got to
be ready to point out actually a lot of
people were predicting it so here's my
challenge to corporate media and I
encourage you to let them know and to
his credit Joe Scarborough actually said
the other day MSNBC has to be live
fact-checking these they are so riddled
with lies they have to be live
fact-checked the challenges demand that
corporate media live fact check the
press briefings put a 90 second delay on
it 90 seconds on Google is more than
enough for a team of producers to find
truth about the things Trump is lying
about if by myself I can catch half the
lies a fully staffed multi million ten
million hundred million dollar operation
has to be able to handle the research
and the graphics required to live fact
check these press briefings airing them
without fact-checking is really easy to
do airing them not airing them at all is
easy to do it's easy to critique as well
right the the real work the value earn
you know should show us that you're
worth something is the message to
corporate media is to run them but live
fact check and you know for the media
outlets that like triggering Trump like
it seems pretty clear at this point
CNN likes to trigger Trump and they've
been you know it's typically CNN asking
some of the tougher questions and good
for them during the press briefings it's
sometimes CNN that will just skip
Trump's part altogether
I get CNN wants to trigger Trump you're
gonna really trigger him by running a
real-time ticker correcting his lies
MSNBC to their credit I believe they did
jump in they had a doctor jump in when
Trump mentioned zinc on I think it was
Wednesday this week they had a doctor
jump in and say this is bogus there's no
evidence that zinc treats coronavirus in
any way and it's it's simply not true
that's good you don't have to have a
guess there the entire time just have
people who know how to search the
internet find the truth about the lies
that Donald Trump is telling and do it
my message to you in the audience is
demand that they do it right to them
tweet them tell them you must live
fact-check they have the resources the
question is do they have the political
will and do they have the strength to
bear what Donald Trump clearly will rain
down upon them for doing it which is not
going to be good Trump is going to be
furious about it but they should do it
it's a service to the American people
it's a service to the world really
because the disinformation that Trump
spreads often goes global it doesn't
raise much like the virus it doesn't
respect the borders of countries we've
got to make them do it let me know what
you think about that suggestion is that
the best strategy for corporate media
with the press briefings
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman quick break
back after this